let's get one thing absolutely straight
if you break into my home and I have a
baseball bat to hand when I find you
I'll beat you possibly to death if
circumstances demand I'd also employ a
golf club poker cricket bat or even a
leftover portion of homemade cauliflower
cheese my son say it's often too tough
to actually eat the way home owner
Richard Osborne Brooks has been treated
after he killed a career criminal who
will woke him in his bed at the dead of
night and forced him downstairs
threatening him with a large screwdriver
has been as unbelievable as it has been
unjustifiable detained by police for
more than 24 hours at one point it
seemed the 78 year old who cares for his
disabled wife was going to be charged
with the murder of the violent criminal
41 years his junior
let's have laws that protect the
innocent and vulnerable victims rather
than even consider prosecuting them you
won't be surprised to know that I
completely agree with you on this and
this was what was shocking in this what
happened Richard Brooks Osbourne as a
results of the police's attitude to many
of what what they call traditional
crimes no like burglary like car theft
their board was all about their federal
with it so so criminals like Henry
Vincent feel completely emboldened to go
into people's houses especially
pensioners hazard because that's who he
targeted all vulnerable pensioners with
any weapon they wanted to do whatever he
wants I think what has shocked me this
week though is what has happened the
fact you should never be arrested in the
first place it was shameful that he was
she was kept in there he was handcuffed
he was he was DNA swapped he was kept
there for two days it's shameful that
any of that ever happened I know they
have to take him in to have a quick chat
with them but you know it's it's good
when somebody breaks into your home with
a screwdriver you know you do what you
have to do but what I think has been
shocking this week is the intimidatory
tactics of the people putting up a
shrine to him in that street because
it's not about it's not about honoring
the man who died it's about intimidating
the people in that street even more than
they are already happy and I just
remember the official police quote that
came from death
detective check
Chief Inspector Simon Harding who was
the investigating officer he said as
expected with any incident where someone
has lost their life my officers carried
out a thorough investigation into the
circumstances of the death whilst there
might be various forms of a debate about
which processes should be used in cases
such as this it was important that the
resident was interviewed by officers
under the appropriate legislation of the
police and evidence in Criminal Evidence
Act not only for the integrity of our
investigation but also so that his
personal and legal rights were protected
you see no no I thought I don't give me
I thought the police felt pretty well
with what was quite difficult
circumstances in the sense well in the
sense that they had to interview him
they hatch them and they had to do that
beyond that they decided to let it go
and they said no he's not guilty and I
think in those circuits just they did
you might think whether I don't know
whether they handcuffed him did they
I read that they handcuffed him when he
was small that would seem you haven't
seem over the top new laws so that in
future gentlemen of 78 years old for
more than 24-hundred like III think you
should do the interview as fast as you
can come to conclusion do you think they
would have let him go within 24 hours if
there hadn't been the public outcry that
there was because I think that's one of
the reasons thank you there are a few
things I want to say you talked about
the flowers like shrine than his family
belts we've got some pictures of that so
I think you're referring to Carroll is
that friends and family of Henry Vincent
who was killed as he was trying to put
up all these flowers you can see they're
outside they've gone up four times here
and here we've got pictures of a local
person taking them down kicking them you
can see him kicking some of the flowers
in the street they're so clearly a very
divisive and difficult experience
especially for the victims of this
burglary who have not been able to go
home I don't think we need new laws and
I'll just tell you the state of the law
and it has changed and since 2016 so the
state
the law is that in self-defense you can
use reasonable force to protect yourself
or your family members in the event of a
home intruder it used to be a
requirement that that use of force had
to be proportionate that's no longer the
case so now you in the scenario you gave
Nick don't have to be thinking about
whether this is proportionate you can do
anything that's considered reasonable to
protect yourself
anything grossly disportionateately
large an to be arrested and detained for
a period of time however we live in a
society characterized by the rule of law
it's in his interest that a procedure
has gone through so that there can be no
yes and let them go because then they
will be exposed to further action
without having a proper defense what I
want to say is I'm not so sure them take
the point the law has reformed and I'm
not so sure it is where I'd be happy
with it because in the precise example
you gave sometimes there's a reason to
chase a person down the street is to
make sure they're not going to get go
and get their mates and come back yeah
and tell their mates that you're alone
at home you overpowered them they you
could atone but the thing is currently
the police are quite clear they don't
want you to chase somebody down the
street and actually I'm saying that
there may be a reason that the police
take the view that once they're out of
your home they're out of your home but
actually I would probably want to detain
that person myself to make sure they're
not alerting others who are usually in
the getaway car and then call the police
and overpower them in whatever way comes
instinctively to me as the exactly and
the other thing I'll point out make is
the only other point I'll make is that I
really feel sorry for the homeowner in
this case because I've just got to say
that what kind of culture in our country
can allow for a scenario to develop
where not only are you now traumatized
because you've had to take somebody's
life which is a terribly traumatic thing
to have to do but of course you have to
do it if you think your family's at risk
but then after that I mean this guy
can't go home anymore his home is
boarded up and it's at risk of arson
attack in revenge attacks for what
people believe he's killed their loved
one and I just feel like
they've lost not only they've lost their
innocence because there had to kill
somebody but we can't go back to their
family home and and what gets me is that
you know all these threats have now been
made against Richard Osborne books the
police's thing that no one has committed
a crime so far so why haven't those
people be arrested but rarely haven't
the people in my harassing people in
that street being arrested because the
people in that stream do feel
intimidated now so what I haven't so why
are the cops standing by on horses eight
or nine of them in the street you know
there was a there was a fracking
demonstration and Lancashire the other
day 50 officers were sent to break up a
knitting circle of women who call
themselves the Lancashire nannies and
yet we have four or five police and
Industry doing nothing I think the
problem you know I agree with you Carol
I think the problem here though is the
instinct that there's something wrong
with the law and actually its policing
practice yeah it's basically sound way
that victims are treated by the way
victims across the board are being
treated and it's not just because a bad
police decision it's also police cuts
it's courts having been closed there is
there's dysfunctions were threatened
with the rest when they when they told
us flowers could he has gone in
voluntarily without having to be
arrested and then given the interview
did it did it have to be an arrest I
don't know the answer because what you
read out said they wanted to give me a
legal protection implants they had to
give me is assisting with inquiry on
suspicion I do I have got a I have got a
baseball bat next to my bed wanna sleep
yes yeah I've had it for years and I
hope I can find it now somebody broke in
I mean the worst thing would you use it
yes you would yes oh I threatened to use
it you know and I certainly wouldn't
chase them down the street that's what
says of the properties God shut them
don't call the police think but I do
think people are entitled to defend
themselves and if everyone around me
with a baseball bat chasing people that
make me feel
a lot of the law is there is the
interpretation it's nice